and I was I feel so embarrassing it's
pretty wild he's jacking off to his
colleagues pretty much this guy's like
I'm sorry for beating this beating it up
you know I don't I don't know what oh my
God our life is over but I was on
[__] PornHub dude I was on a [__]
regular ass normal website his excuse
was and there was an ad he got tempted
and wanted to look into it and went down
a rabbit hole and it was good it's gross
and I'm sorry I really am but it's a
thing except I was trying to look for
big wet glasses
and then I got this deep fake video we
[__] Pokemon in it and I feel like
[__] I was already hot
really that's amazing I'm paraphrased
like all of our chicks have deep fakes
right so like and we all beat off to
them and we all I was hammering it